das nächste feld und ich hab auch sein
spitzname ist ja ich habe auch keine
burg mensch aber ich habe dafür ich hab
da wo ich hab' ich habe in meiner kiste
ist holz in meiner kiste in meiner kiste
holzer junge weiße ich habe reisen und
stück habe ich habe keine workbench du
musst noch zu meiner kiste finden
zufällig habe ihre koordinaten der kiste
ja da musst du nur hin warteten die
koordinaten ja aber dann kommt aller
kurz schreibt ihr macht nochmal da co2
daten sagt man ist - 299 99 jahre und 1
721 und y 66 aber unwichtig nicht in der
höhle koloss bei mir wird es dann ein
grüner elektronik rettung setzt ihm die
hochkommen helga da ist die rettung
ach so ja was ist ein bisschen weit weg
sie macht ich hoffe ich komme nicht
durch
ach du scheiße ich weiß nicht wie ich da
hinkommen soll
ich fühle mich sowieso ein batzen
falschgeld und spitzhacke jetzt richtig
schlimm ist so wie ich vorbereitet conny
erhältlich sind alle kaputt gegangen man
ist schnell jahren abbauen
ich laufe den weg hoch das sieht ganz
gut aus
das sind spiele und skelett
mit 35 holz gefunden geil
ach ja wie ich meine nichte minenschacht
das stimmt dann war da ja überall holz
auch verdammt ich blöd man das hinkriegt
jetzt nicht lang
verdammt ich hab mich so verlaufen bitte
leute weg gefunden hat ich glaub ja ich
glaube ja ich habe ja ich hab doch nicht
aufnehmen
manchmal reichen april topspiel ist es
raus das war okay tue ich bin jetzt raus
ich mach ich dass meine
war das ein kick
work bench
auch nicht ausgeleuchtet es techniker
sind so krass
mozilla hat er weist den weg frei
gesprengt wenn doch ein bauer noch eine
kiste
ich glaube ich einfach hier hoch ich
finde ich mit meinen sachen lagern ich
bin um mehr ärzte ihn geholt
weißt du was wir machen sollten vw
beetle r zusammen
wir sollten uns so ein buch abbauen dann
können wir seine tag verdoppelt
geschrieben ehrlich ja da sieht man
doppelt so viele sachen und so geil ich
bin da ich geschafft wie bastelt man
sich den ball irgendwie glaube ich so
allgaier mit grill oder so ich da man
braucht diamanten dafür
ich hab ja sonst wäre jetzt aber lebt 2
da ist natürlich gut
was könnt ihr alles wegwerfen knochen
story präsent wo das gestein hieß
alles was jetzt weg an komplexen kiste 2
jetzt nehme ich natürlich wieder mit
das weg sand kann weg bist du daraus
machst erhöhen
ich bin oben bei ich bin um bei unserem
robert kisten weißt schon so ich brauche
auch halliburton kakaobohnen kommen auch
weg die kannst du haben im betrieb
hinter mir genau wo ich mich umgedreht
habe realistisch minecraft sehr
realistisch auch noch ein paar sehr
schöne feier steinbruch ja gibt noch
einen zombie comeback noch ein skelett
oh ja noch ein sehr geiles bled kopf ich
glaube ich jetzt auch noch auf 13 die 2
alles in die höhle rein so und jetzt
irgendwann verliert man nicht jeden
tastatur klick ja schlimm nicht richtig
richtig scheiße einfach nur sagst du
eigentlich für eine immer weg zu recht
ich weiß ich solche rausgehen oder soll
ich mir noch ein paar er das so
verlockend ja darum beschweren zu mir
weil ich mit jeder level 35 er das
richtig geld
die sind runter runter vor allem die
höhle hohle die höhle heute einfach
nicht auf ist einfach so dass jetzt
einfach überall sachen ich glaub ich geh
wieder weiter runter welt aber die
chance dass ich der wie diamanten findet
also jetzt von jedem noch ein bisschen
mit weiß nicht ob so viel von allen
sachen es ist richtig und normal
ich möchte mir jetzt gerne spitzhacken
uns so was man aber wo habe ich ihn hier
aluminium ohr einmal kurz steinofen kann
ich auf jeden fall eine kiste da packen
hast was mache ich was mache reisen
reisen muss so was was durchzubrennen
kohle habe ich die kohle colo colo colo
ich habe letztes in einer lustvoll
gecancelt nicht aber ich weiß dass das
ist ja genau
und zwar habe ich einfach so weisen
gefunden und so zu dem lied singe ich
einfach so ein bisschen so eisen
blablabla ich will aber diamanten so ein
bisschen gesungen
valletta zu einer auf youtube hochsaison
viel besser als der koloss voll geil ich
cool dass die leute so was machen ja
aber ich finde die kohle von auch schon
sinnlos aber grandios aber hat er ja ich
weiß nicht mal wie es jetzt schlecht
aber ich finds lustig so gründete ich
habe trotzdem witzig ist auch cool
eisen ist was schönes ein dadurch mit
der rahmen schnitts der entdeckten der
abschluss wird durch durchkommt den kohl
sonnendeck
das ist auf jeden fall eine krasse sache
und jetzt hat er selber 60.000 ja keine
ahnung oder 100 1200 euro fiel
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht genau was
ist schon krass wenn einer von euch
kennt ihr beim schreiben viele
abonnenten hat so erstmal schön das
essen dann auch schon lange keine themen
mehr aber das heißt eigentlich dass wir
hier auch genügend kommentieren können
du hast du ein thema auf dem herzen dass
du ansprechen würdest du ansprechen
könnte das bringt doch nichts auf dem
herzen
nein was ein bisschen haut und knochen
alles alles okay welt die kids dvv
googelt das erste das ich so traurig an
geht es mit meiner hohen kiste dann bin
ich glücklich
zwei spitzhacken fledermaus hey ich hab
die fledermaus getötet zu deiner höhen
kiste zu welcher zweiten ach so ich habe
schon zwei ich geht's wieder darunter
woher kommen bin ich muss ich muss noch
mal eine rechnung begleichen rechnung
begleichen
da haben wir sicherlich paar leute mit
mir angelegt die dachten keystone weg
wohl die können das nur machen wenn er
mir ich hab vergessen die fackel
mitzunehmen da da da da dam und hole
fackeln okay ist der mannschaft ist
wieder so ein projekt das ist stöcker
darf ist holzstöcke draus machst alles
euch auch an holz was mach ich jetzt zu
stücken kommen jedoch sterben
danke stöcke kohle und 840 dinge ans
nein nein ein echter meine ich will
diamanten und nicht diesen ganzen
anderen hinter mir gesehen wir versuchen
den moment zu töten
das haben wir schon geschafft dass wir
keine ausrüstung haben also co2 und ich
hänge vom blöden links fest spielt also
spinnennetze also lahm ist okay dass
eine kiste in italien schafft diese
meistens aber ganz gut bestückt oder
sonne da sind fit tin cans kenner von
day sid das sind kupfer drin und eine
community umfeld hack a howard spielt
jaja coelho in amerika entfernen weil
dieses rohr how werde sich an bevor das
rohr auf englisch heißt das wissen die
kinder erst mal googeln
so wird das geschrieben deswegen wird
entweder aol danach klingt bei der kam
nämlich kinder an und meinte zu einer
älteren frau
hohoho und habe das skript von wie
horror wollte die frau dafür angezeigt
diese kinder sind wohl beleidigt haben
oder ihn wie so was und deswegen gibt es
da jetzt wohl nicht mehr darf man nicht
mehr
hohoho machen als wäre das loben oder
sowas will ich ein bisschen fad aber ist
übertrieben die reaktion aber die
amerikaner auch leute mal fünf millionen
von schmerz geht im verklagt und sich
aber im fußball auch schon krass dass
man da zum beispiel bastian
schweinsteiger der fall
der musste da einfach mal irgendwie zu
1000 euro strafe bezahlen weil er die
falschen schuhe beim training hatte
1000 euro ja aber ich hatte feuer
gefangen